l'odore del pane il pane ha un odore
meraviglioso
eppure è strano perché non è un autore
naturale è una cosa cucinata
ma forse è così buono ci attrae così
tanto
proprio perché è una cosa cucinata
cucinata da qualcuno che si prende cura
di noi
vi siete mai chiesti chi ha cominciato a
cucinare sicuramente non sofia loren e
l'oro di napoli e neanche le massaie
napoletane ma forse secondo i moderni
antropologi è stata una scimmia questa
scimmia questa scimmia
buongiorno è stato un incendio nella
foresta e ha scoperto i tuberi che si
erano scaldati sotto al fuoco e ha
pensato che forse questi tuberi potevano
essere buoni per lei e pian piano ha
cominciato a utilizzarli a sostituirli
nella preparazione di tutti i giorni
quindi anziché passare le giornate a
masticare queste foglie abbastanza
noiose ha cominciato a sostituire piano
piano dei vegetali cotti che cosa è
successo
pro di vegetali cotti sono più soffici
le mascelle della scimmia si sono
ridotte quindi la dimensione delle
mascelle diminuita la dimensione del
cervello è aumentata perché si era
spazio nella scatola cranica e quindi
questa scimmia ha cominciato a diventare
più intelligente e quindi pian piano ha
cominciato a pensare ed è diventata un
uomo quindi attenzione la scimmia è
diventata un uomo perchè ha cominciato a
utilizzare alimenti cotti
questo è estremamente affascinante
perché perché noi sappiamo oggi che la
cucina è il luogo della trasmissione del
sapere sappiamo che cucinare per i
nostri cari è una cosa estremamente
importante e oggi io da king degli
alimenti vi dico che i cibi cotti sono
più buoni sono più digeribili sono
spesso più saporiti non sempre
ovviamente c'è anche qualcosa di crudo
che è molto buono e allora cucinare è
importante per la nostra evoluzione e
non è un caso che il mediterraneo la
culla delle civiltà e anche il posto nel
mondo dove c'è una grandissima
attenzione al cibo e noi siamo al centro
del mediterraneo
noi sappiamo quanto è importante per noi
non solo mangiare ma parlare di mangiare
noi spendiamo tantissimo tempo a pensare
cosa mangeremo la sera della vigilia
parliamo di quello che mangeremo al
pranzo di natale
quindi è vero che i mediterranei che noi
specialmente italiani del sud non
mangiamo per vivere ma viviamo un
pochino anche per mangiare e questa è
una caratteristica nostra importante che
ricordata la vorrei che la
tendenzialmente per la fine della mia
del mio top è importante noi giochiamo
nello stare a tavola invitiamo la
fidanzata a cena fuori e per noi è un
momento in cui attraverso il cibo
facciamo passare anche tante altre cose
e il mondo ce lo riconosce nel mondo se
parlate a tavola italiano di capiscono
spaghetti maccheroni pizza mozzarella ma
anche espresso latte macchiato imparano
anche le parole difficili basta che
siano italiane ed associate al cibo ok
il cibo e gioia e cultura però adesso se
ci pensate vicino al cibo vengono
associate tante cose negative
prima di tutto un sacco di fobie di cui
oggi non mi voglio neanche parlare poi
c'è il problema della dell'obesità del
fatto che questo cibo ma nasce buono ma
ci fa ingrassare è vero sono problemi ma
c'è un problema molto più grande che
bisogna studiare e il problema di come
fare a nutrire il pianeta nel 2050 ci
saranno tre milioni tre miliardi di
persone in più
non se ne andranno tutte su marte come
avete sentito prima questi tre miliardi
di persone in più le dovremo far
mangiare quindi oddio come faremo a far
mangiare tutte queste persone
ecco questo è un problema centrale che
si studia nell'università dove gli
adesso lavoro in olanda a vaghe ningen
far mangiare tutte queste persone
allora cominciamo a dire una cosa non è
vero che nel mondo non c'è abbastanza
cibo
il problema da un lato e lo spreco
dovremmo sprecarne meno dall'altro è il
fatto che il cibo viene essenzialmente
da tre fonti grano mais e riso
queste tre fonti che cosa hanno
buonissime facciamo e di sottil a pasta
però hanno tante tanti carboidrati e
poche proteine e a noi le proteine ci
servono
ci servono per crescere ci servono per
mantenere i muscoli queste proteine da
dove le prendiamo dai cibi
sostanzialmente animali tra carne pesce
e derivati le possiamo prendere dai
vegetali e vero le possiamo prendere
dalla soia principalmente ma anche la
soia è limitata consuma terra per essere
per poterla coltivare consuma acqua e
queste risorse sono finite serve troppa
terra serve troppa acqua per produrre
proteine
quindi il problema è che le proteine non
sono sostenibili
teoricamente ne dovremmo mangiare di
meno ma in realtà non riusciamo a
mangiarne di meno quindi il problema
quale e trovare nuove fonti di proteine
la cosa più promettente e cercare gli
organismi unicellulari come per esempio
il lievito il lievito e una buona fonte
di proteine oppure delle alghe delle
microalghe non le alghe che trovate a
mare ma le microalghe che sono una ricca
fonte di proteine oppure dei funghi
oppure c'è adesso la grande moda degli
insetti insetti sono potenzialmente una
bellissima fonte di proteine
ecco già adesso la vostra mente state
pensando ai grilli nel piatto io non ve
li faccio vedere apposta perché non
pensiate che questo sia il problema
questo è il modo di ragionare ognuno
pensa partendo da da noi stessi invece
il problema dell'accettazione del
consumatore è l'ultimo dei problemi
il problema vero è un altro il problema
è che noi viviamo in questa società nel
mercato globale dobbiamo dare da
mangiare a 9 miliardi di persone e 9
miliardi di persone vanno nei
supermercati e comprano delle cose che
costano pochi euro per kg quindi bisogna
produrre le farine quanto costano meno
di un euro al chilo
quindi noi dobbiamo produrre in grande
quantità a poco prezzo altrimenti è
uguale ci sarà sempre fame nel mondo
allora come si fa il problema è produrre
grandi quantità di questi nuovi alimenti
a pochi euro per kg
una ricerca bellissima sulle micro alghe
l'abbiamo fatta con i colleghi della
dell'università federico ii al
dipartimento di agraria dove cresciamo
queste micro alghe che vi dicevo prima
la spirulina la bodrio cocus spirulina
forse qualcuno di voi l'ha sentita
compra le pillole oppure degli
integratori
quanto costano tantissimo non possiamo
pensare di farli di far mangiare il
mondo con una cosa che costa 50 euro al
chilo o 10 euro una confezione di
pillole non è possibile
noi abbiamo trovato delle tecnologie
povere come queste vasche che vedete che
riescono ad abbattere il prezzo di
crescita di queste micro alghe e allora
è possibile metterle come ingredienti
per esempio nella pasta e si fa la pasta
con la spirulina e questa è una pasta a
un prezzo accettabile per gli insetti
voi pensate allo schifo degli insetti
nel piatto per me per noi ricercatori il
problema è farli crescere come si fanno
crescere tonnellate di insetti è un
problema molto difficile che si sta
studiando e adesso per esempio siamo
riusciti a produrre insetti che possono
sostituire le farine di pesce le farine
di pesce vengono usati
dell'alimentazione del in acquacoltura
per esempio dei salmoni e adesso anziché
prendere calamari e altri animali del
mare quindi i cosiddetti st
itc si possono sostituire con queste
farine di insetti quindi fine della
prima parte il problema di risolvere la
fame nel mondo di dare calorie a 9
miliardi di persone
non vi preoccupate ci arriveremo c'è
però un altro problema invece di cui ci
dobbiamo occupare vi dovete occupare è
il problema della cultura del cibo vede
questo ve lo ricorderete è l'expo di
milano grande evento dell'anno scorso
lo slogan del esplodi milano era nutrire
il pianeta
ora se ci pensate è questo che vorreste
per voi essere nutriti questo che
pensate per i vostri figli nipoti
nutriti no lo date per scontato che
sarete nutriti quello che voi pensate mi
auguro e fargli assaporare la gioia del
cibo quello che abbiamo detto prima il
bello dello stare a tavola quello che ci
contraddistingue come meridionali come
italiani del sud
amiamo il cibo ed è questo che noi
dobbiamo insegnare al pianeta
non siamo da soli c'è tanta cultura del
cibo nel mondo
noi sappiamo che lo spaghetto colpo
motorino si fa in un certo modo con la
foglia di basilico messa alla fine i
cinesi sanno che gli scorpioni si devono
fare allo spiedo arrostiti sul legno
verde
noi sappiamo che le zucchine alla
scapece vanno fatte con la menta in
zimbabwe
questi vermi siano verni mopane sanno
che si devono fare con un trito taglio e
di pomodorino e cultura e cultura del
cibo
il nostro problema non sono quelli che
hanno cultura sono quelli che non ce
l'hanno la cultura del cibo che sono la
maggioranza quello questi sono quelli
che possono mangiare anche la pasta ma
si mangiano la pasta in scatola possono
mangiare anche gli insetti ma loro
richiamano sostituti della carne
e sono hamburger mangiano cose dolci e
non sanno che cos'è la cassata riempiono
tutto di maionese non hanno mai
assaggiato lo zazzi chi sono loro il
problema e sono loro io questa è la mia
vera paura sono loro che vinceranno
perché quando loro vinceranno ci sarà
una bella global diet tutti mangeremo
più o meno le stesse cose perfettamente
nutriti ma che tristezza
a meno che a meno che noi proprio noi
quelli che ce l'hanno la cultura del
cibo
elaboriamo una strategia vincente
cosa abbiamo fatto fino adesso quando
pensate la strategia del cibo quale la
difesa del made in italy
giochiamo in difesa e come direbbe il
mio amico di prima se tu giochi in
difesa prima o poi un gol lo prendi
allora non dobbiamo giocare in difesa
perché se pensiamo a nutrire il mondo
non possiamo nutrire tutto il mondo con
il cibo italiano non ce la possiamo fare
non tutti nel mondo possono mangiare
quello che viene prodotto nella piccola
italia però possiamo esportare la
cultura del cibo e questo l'ho imparato
molto bene in olanda dove lavoro adesso
non andranno una strategia che chiamano
il triangolo d'oro che mette insieme lo
stato gli istituti di ricerca e le
imprese alimentari che cosa fanno col
triangolo d'oro vanno nei diversi paesi
del mondo trovano gli studenti migliori
e li portano a studiare in olanda gli
insegnano le cose e intanto le aziende
stanno in quel paese imparano la cultura
di quel paese si insediano in quel paese
e cominciano a migliorare i prodotti
locali sembra astratto vi faccio un
esempio su cui stiamo lavorando adesso
siamo in zambia e in zambia esiste una
grande popolazione rurale che pian piano
si sta spostando nelle grandi città
agi dello zambia è molto popolare un
prodotto che si chiama ma bisi il ma
bisi è uno yogurt sostanzialmente un
latte fermentato che noi abbiamo
studiato ed è buonissimo con dei
fermenti lattici all'interno molto buoni
anche per la salute cosa succede che
questo ma b si viene prodotto con il
latte della mungitura serale la sera
viene munto il latte ma non lo possono
portare da nessuna parte per i trasporti
per l'elettricità e quindi questo latte
per non buttarlo viene fermentato e
viene fermentato in quelle zucche che
vedete
ora noi stiamo facendo un progetto con
questi villaggi
abbiamo migliorato lo zampino ma visita
abbiamo stabilizzato e adesso questo ma
b si può arrivare nelle grandi città
dove trovano le persone che lo
mangiavano prima ve lo mangiavano prima
di trasferirsi nella città quindi lo
stanno riscoprendo riutilizzando la loro
cultura del cibo che hanno allo stesso
tempo un miglioramento nutrizionale
famose proteine che dicevamo all'inizio
quindi questo a livello di sistema e
quello che possiamo fare
ma c'è anche un'altra cosa che è quello
che può fare ognuno di voi
ognuno di voi può parlare di cibo può
spiegare quello che per noi è naturale
gli ingredienti la freschezza
l'importanza dei sapori singoli non
mettere 22 ingredienti sopra una pizza
perché è più buona la pizza pomodoro
mozzarella
basta non serve riempirla riempirla di
cose questo pane questo pane che vi ho
fatto vedere all'inizio perché è buono è
buono perché ieri sera qualcuno l'ha
impastato stanotte a lievitato
stamattina presto qualcuno si è alzato
per prepararlo e noi lo troviamo
normalmente ci sembra naturale ad ogni
angolo
ma questo nel mondo mica lo conoscono
nel mondo mangiano questo questo pane
molliccio e senza sapore questo mangiano
questo nutre come questo
le stesse calorie non fa né bene né male
nutre uguale ma io questo a tavola non
ce lo metto detto questo ecco il
semplice quello che vi chiedo come
messaggio da ricordare molto semplice
spiegate a tutti come mettersi a tavola
grazie